yes so shadow crew uh
what's so as we're
you started with love started with love
so now we're we're you know doing these
schemes online
i'm selling i'm selling to these i'm
programming these satellite dss cards
and you
one of the interesting things and you
still see that to this day is
something will happen
that will create
an industry for criminals all right so
what happened is
canada canadian judge rules about the
same time that i'm doing these satellite
cards canadian judge comes out and says
hey
it's legal for my citizens to pirate
those signals and his reasoning was is
since rca doesn't sell the systems up
here my citizens can pirate it
okay
so what happens is overnight about the
same time paypal comes into play so
paypal is coming right online at about
the same time
overnight
little cottage industry pops up in the
united states you go down to best buy
buy the system for a hundred dollars
take it out in the parking lot open
system up pull it open box up pull the
system out pull the card out throw the
system away program the card ship its
ass to canada 500 pop
started doing that
business is good
making you know three four thousand
dollars a week doing that i'm like yeah
that's good
i have so many orders i can't fill all
the orders and quickly think to myself
why do i need to fill any of them
they're in canada i'm down here
you know who are they going to complain
to because i already found out people
don't complain all right they're not
going to complain to anybody
so i start not questioning candidates
especially in canada
and i'm i'm having them send money
that's when paypal's first into play
and it amazes me that everybody is using
paypal
it's like you don't even have to really
ask they're like can we pay by yeah you
can pay all day long by paypal and
paypal had no clue what they were doing
with security
so
it's like okay
so they're sending money to paypal i'm
having the paypal cashed out to uh to
bank accounts in my name at that point
and i get scared because by that point
i'm still in four to six thousand
dollars a week
and i'm like somebody's gonna be looking
at money laundering
so get into my head i'm like best thing
that i can do is get a fake driver's
license open up a bank account using
that driver's license cash out at the
atm
good no idea where to get a fake id not
a clue
so i get online looked around spent a
couple weeks looking around thought i
found a guy he went by the screen name
of fake id man
thought i found a guy sent him 200 send
him a picture dude rips me off
oh i got played he had he had a little a
website set up with reviews and i'm like
oh it's all legitimate he's building
that trust that i talked about
so
the end result i got pissed
and
there was no site
that dealt with anything criminal or
cyber crime related the only real avenue
you had was an irc chat session internet
relay chat and that i'm sure you've been
on that this it's this rolling chat
board you don't know who the hell you're
talking to most of them are full of [ __ ]
you can't trust anybody and you're
sitting there trying to conduct business
so you know if somebody claims they've
got a product or service do they have it
does it work or they just want to rip
you off because in those channels
everyone's a criminal
i kept looking around and i've happened
upon a website called counterfeit
library and counterfeit library only
dealt with counterfeit degrees and
certificates as the degree meal type
stuff
but they had a forum
and no one was using the forum so i
basically get on there and [ __ ] every
day
i got ripped off don't know what to do
about the same time i start doing that
two other guys show up one's named mr x
he's out of los angeles the other guy's
named beelzebub he's out of uh moose jaw
saskatchewan
and we all become buddies
so you know a few weeks of me bitching a
few weeks of them responding
blzb gets me on icq and he sends me a
message he's like i went by the screen
name of gollum at that point got him fun
and he's like got him i can make you a
fake driver's license and i was like
well [ __ ] do it that he's like
well i'm going to charge you for it i'm
like yeah you are he's like i am
i was like no you're not
and he's like look man he said
this business if you're going to do this
you have to trust people
or you're going to fail
he said so i want to charge you 200. but
i'm going to send you a driver's license
well by this point i'm friends with the
people who own
counterfeit library where email and chat
and everything else
and i tell him i'm like okay
i'm going to send you 200
that way when you rip me off i'll have
them ban you and i don't have to deal
with you anymore and he's like bet i'm
like okay
so i sent him 200
sending my picture
two weeks later i get her driver's
license name is steven schwecke out of
ohio and uh real guy worked at adp
payroll to this day works at adp is
where the guy works
got the driver's license
and to me at that point in time it was
the prettiest thing that i had ever seen
you know i never seen a fake id before
i thought it was great turns out you
know looking back it's like
so but it is uh
kind of a strong first step in creating
a fake identity very strong very strong
so this so that was like
gaskel just uh
on the
on the point he made
that if you're going to be successful in
this
you should have people you trust
is he right on that oh he's absolutely
right
he's absolutely so you have to have this
is like mob
you have to you have to have an inner
circle
you trust you know i'm sure you've
probably heard me say this before
successful cybercrime
all right
there are three necessities to being
successful online if you're a criminal
three necessities are gathering data
committing the crime and then cashing it
out
all three of those necessities have to
work in conjunction if they don't the
crime fails
the problem and it's a huge problem is
that one guy
can't do all three things
you know you've got you've got the
people who gather the data basically the
the general store sells people who sell
pii credit card logins
data tools they always sell the spoofed
phone numbers or rdps stuff like that
a lot of the times those people don't
know how to commit the crime and those
people certainly don't know how to
launder the money out put cash in pocket
so you've got
either because of a skill level
sometimes a geographic location
limits what that individual can do all
right so you have to rely
on people who are good in areas where
you are not
in order for that crime to succeed and
that
means you have to trust those people
so what happens with shadow crew all
right so counterfeit library is the
start all right
counterfeit library transitions over to
shadow crew right before that transition
there's a ukrainian guy by the name of
dimitri golob he was a spammer at that
point in time he saw what we were doing
with with counterfeit library and he
liked it
he was getting all these credit card
details and this kid i mean he's a kid
this kid has an idea and his idea was i
wonder if people would buy stolen credit
card details it's pretty good uh ukraine
russian accent so yeah he picks up the
phone he calls his buddies
they call their buddies they have a
physical conference in odessa 150 of
these cyber criminals show up and they
launch this idea this launches a website
called carter planet which is the
genesis of all modern credit card theft
as we know it alright so
remember i mentioned those three
necessities of cybercrime
dimitri had all the credit data in the
world and he partnered with all these
other ukrainians who had all this data
as well the problem was is so much fraud
had been committed on that eastern side
of europe that every card had been shut
down even if you were a legitimate card
holder and tried to cash it out you
weren't doing it at that point
so again those three necessities
gathering data committing crime cashing
out dimitri had the data they could
commit the crime they could not put cash
in pocket so we were running counterfeit
library one day i get this message or
not a message one day script shows up
and he posts just on the general forum
he posts hey i've got credit card data
give me an address give me a burner
phone number wait five business days
order whatever you want to we had never
seen
anything like that we were a paypal
fraud and ebay fraud side is what we
were and fake drivers licenses
so then and we had i guess we had two 3
000 members at that point so
the response from the members
was
that can't be real you've got to be law
enforcement it's got to be in trying to
get us arrested and everything else
what
let me backtrack a little bit so
the driver's license that i had got
beelzebub had an idea what he wanted to
do is he wanted to sell
driver's licenses
mr x wanted to sell social security
cards he made a very passable social
security guard
me i didn't i had no skill level on that
i knew paypal fraud and ebay fraud so
bl's bub was like tell you what
you be the reviewer
that way you get every product or
service that comes in they'll have to
send it to you or let you have access to
it you can learn the entire game
and because you're not selling anything
it gives you legitimacy on the reviews
alright so i started out as a reviewer
the only reviewer on counterfeit library
so over the next year
beelzebub turns out he was a pot grower
he goes back to growing pot because he
wasn't making [ __ ] selling driver's
licenses mr x
about a year and a half in he gets
arrested cashing out uh driver's credit
card not credit cards cashing out to
casinos doing some [ __ ] with that
so i'm the only guy left standing and
i'm at the top of the heap so and it
becomes this thing where if i review
somebody
they make a lot of money if i don't you
don't do business here so script shows
up saying he's got this i'm the only
reviewer on site
people think he's law enforcement
first week it goes like that after a
while i'm like okay i gotta do something
and i'm scared man because i'm like he
may be law enforcement so i get him on
icq and i'm like hey you have to be
reviewed he's like what the hell is that
so i tell him what it is he's like you
reviewed me and i was like yeah that's
the idea
so give them a drop address give them a
burner phone number
wait five business days and i try to hit
dell for five thousand dollars the order
fails i get back on icq hey man it
didn't work he's like give me one more
chance i was like look i'll give you one
more chance but it's your ass after that
he's like one more chance like okay give
him another address another phone number
wait another five business days
hit thompson's computer warehouse for
four thousand dollars dell for five
thousand dollars order goes through get
the products in
i post that
review on counterfeit library and
literally overnight we turn from an ebay
paypal fraud site to a credit theft site
and that becomes
a lot of money really quickly for
members so we were doing
now it's called cmp fraud card not
present fraud so you hit you use hit an
online merchant with stolen credit card
data back then a a fairly experienced
fraudster could profit 30 to 40 000 a
month
okay
just buying you know laptops what have
you and cashing out you know put them on
ebay for sale and sell them like that
and 30 to 40k a month was the profit on
that
script had a lot of buddies he had
people like roman vega these other guys
that would sell not just credit card
data but counterfeit physical credit
cards as well
we had um counterfeit not stolen so
constantly counterfeit
that that must be tough to do
so the connections must be harder than
crazy drivers that's crazy so you know
you're back so what's what boa initially
had and i became the the united states
salesperson for boa
but what he had was is he was the first
dumps provider
in the united states so on the back of
your credit or debit card there's a
magnetic stripe
three data tracks on the stripe there's
the first data track is customer's name
second data track is the card number
forward slash
16 digit algorithm outside of that
that's important we'll get back to that
in a few minutes third data track is
called indiscriminate data no one uses
it all right
so what's bought and sold
is the second data track it's called the
dump and the reason that's sold is when
you go into a shop
you insert the card or you swipe the
card the only information that's sent
out for verification is the second data
track all right that goes to the
processor bank for verification
the first data track that customers name
shows up on the screen of the cashier in
front of you so what typically happens
is is you buy 10 of these dumps you get
10 counterfeit cards
in code track 2 on all 10 cards track
one you create one fake driver's license
track one is just the name of that one
fake driver's license that way when you
go in the shop swipe the card track two
sent off for verification track one
shows up on the screen in front of the
cashier
if you ever ask for id you pull out the
fake id everyone's a nice warm fuzzy you
walk out with cameras rolex track one
could be a it doesn't have to be
connected it's not connected attractive
not connected at all all right
that's that's one of the big problems
all right yeah
so
script brought a host of technical
people
into that type of environment all
committing credit card theft we had
proxy providers we had all these people
that were doing this stuff
we start making a lot of money a lot and
the reason that happens is again script
did not have the ability to cash out so
he was reduced to selling things at the
same time he's looking for how do i make
more money all right
the ukrainians happened upon
this thing called the cvv1 breach or
hack that's what it's what they call it
so what happens is remember i told you
of track two
card number
forward slash
sixteen digit algorithm you gotta know
the algorithm to encode it so you can
swipe the card or take it to the atm
machine all right atm
you got to know it now we were fishing
data from hell i mean we were we were
doing a lot of fishing a lot we were
getting pins we were getting card
numbers but you can't get that algorithm
so the ukrainians start testing stuff
what they found out was
no bank
had implemented the hash on track two
so you take the card number forward
slash any 16 digits it would encode
take it to the atm pull cash out because
you got the pin
all right
started doing that
well wait uh sorry i'm trying to
understand so
that means
so if there's no
ha
are they generating random numbers or do
they have valid numbers for track two no
numbers needed at all as long as just
the track two was a complete track two
so it's a valid track too
that doesn't
match so the pin
is the thing that gets you in but so
back then all right back then what we're
talking about is you need to typically
today you need a whole track too you
need that valid track too all right you
need the you need the 16 digit card
number
forward slash and then whatever that
algorithm is out of the side of it all
right
back then none of the banks had
implemented that algorithm so while the
algorithm was there you didn't need it
to encode
interesting interesting
so you can make a lot of money
uh with uh physical of
that
debit cards card not present fraud
remember i told you was 30 to 40 000 a
month all right that turned into 30 to
40 000 a day yeah the ukrainians again
they can't cash it out
they've got all the data on the planet
but they can't cash it out those three
necessities of cybercrime so the deal
became you have to rely on the americans
tell you what we'll give you 40
so you had all these cashiers that were
40 of 40 000 a day yeah we'll take that
all right
send the rest of it over to by western
union or what have you to ukrainian
contact that's before cryptocurrency
came into play now you had a couple of
forerunners with e-gold and liberty
reserve things like that
but back then it starts out with western
union then it becomes prepaid cards
sending track information over loading
the card up like that and then finally
you get to e-gold liberty reserve and
today it's with crypto that's that's
used um
started stealing a lot of money a lot
and that got law enforcement attention
so we started to see
i mean this it's a crazy ass story we
started to see
ips coming in from law enforcement
agencies government agencies because
back then they didn't know how to shield
their identity either so you saw you saw
secret service you saw dod you saw all
these like and you're like
that's interesting
you know and
at the same time
we had
it was called a hack but it wasn't a
hack
we had a guy that worked at t-mobile in
los angeles this is the same guy that
back then published paris hilton's phone
contact list
made a lot of news
not only did he do that but it turned
out that the los angeles secret service
agency was using t-mobile phones so he's
getting text messages of the secret
service investigating shadow crew and he
posts those damn things on shadow crew
so i'm sitting there going head of the
pile i'm sitting there going
this is not going to end well this is
not going to end well
so at the same time i had access i'd
started out with access to the indiana
state sex offenders registry and i was
using that to create bank accounts
london money out and i would sell the
bank accounts and stuff like that
they shut that down the next database i
had access to was the texas driver's
license database and started using that
to create fake driver's licenses what
have you and then finally we happened
upon the california death index
all right
complete information mother's maiden
socials dobs all that and it's like
got to be a use for that well you can
use it to create identities all day long
my idea was i wonder
if you could take somebody that's died
and then file for social security death
benefit not death benefits but social
security benefits for that individual
and get that recurring paycheck in so
that takes a lot of research to start
seeing if you can do that how does the
federal government know if you're dead
do federal indexes reference state
indexes you've got all these questions
that pop up well it turns out federal
indexes don't reference state indexes
it's against the law
it also turns out the only way the
federal government knows you're dead
is prior to 1998
the family had to file a social security
death benefit
for that person
all right
prior to 98 of course most people don't
right prior to 98 it took the family
after 98 the hospital can do it funeral
home can do it or the family could do it
so a lot more people have it filed after
if they've died but it's still there's a
lot of people a lot of people
because that death benefit's only like
219 dollars yeah okay nobody's thinking
about that [ __ ]
so i started to apply for social
security
benefits
nope
numbers dormant so they want you to come
in for a physical interview here i am
you know i'm 32
you're not going to pass as a 65 year
old so no
so the next idea i had was
i wonder if you could file income tax
returns on these people
turns out you can
all day long
so i started doing that
and i started to steal once i got ramped
up because you test everything you know
you're testing make sure you got to
figure out what the deposit instrument
is and everything else and once you get
all that lined out
i started to steal 160 000 a week every
week for 10 months out of the year
by
paying taxes
by filing fake uh yeah filing paid tax
returns so you find a business yes and
the way the system worked is
the irs will issue a refund on somebody
before they're able to verify that that
person worked for an employer
still works like that today
all right so and you're keeping the
amounts relatively low keep them three
thousand dollars
all right
amounts are very low but you're still
able to achieve scale because this is
large index i got to where and i was
manual later on a couple buddies of mine
went automated with it wait you would go
doing this by hand so there's no code
involved all manual wow i'd file return
once every six minutes
work 10 hours a day
three days a week so clicking on so to
typing fast and click one return every
six minutes
that's changing ip that's uh changing
address everything else will return
every six minutes
for three days a week fourth day i would
take a road trip plot out a map of atms
and then the next two days
cash out bam bam bam bam bam all right
come back home rinse and repeat um turns
out that a backpack i don't see any
sitting around here but a backpack will
hold 150 000 of 20s is what it'll hold
so i put 150k and 20s in a backpack i
had a spare bedroom i'd come in
toss the backpack in the bedroom this is
very very important information and the
fact that you know it is uh is also very
yeah first we started with a volume of
coal that weighs a ton and now a
backpack holds a hundred fifty thousand
dollars of points
and then you can multiply that by five
for hundreds
yeah uh
most of the time it's 20 it's coming out
atm right
each 20 ways
each 20 ways a gram so those actually go
by weight which is what federal
authorities do when they get a pallet of
cash they just weigh it oh
they just should they just weigh it so
150 k is seven and a half keys of cash
oh that's pretty light
that's bad yeah did you get big backpack
go do a good uh run with david goggins
with it nice i like it
the fact you know this is great so wait
uh where does that come in with the
backpack so what happens is i didn't
know how to launder money all right so
you know i'm throwing cash in in the
spare bedroom one day you open up the
bedroom and you're like
gotta do something with those backpacks
that's when you start learning how to
wander money you know cash-based
businesses things like that i had a
production company had a couple of
detailing company i was thinking about
going into food trucks
things like that in charleston actually
can you pause on that to take a tangent
there how does my money laundering
uh work i mean at that time and what
years are we talking about this is uh
by the time the tax return schemes
go into play we're talking uh 2002 2003
is when tax returns start and so what uh
at that time and what you're aware of
now
how it evolved how does monday money
laundering work
you know it's not that much different
it's really not uh
you you get a cash-based business start
laundering the money or putting the
money through that saying the
transactions are legal you
then start depositing into bank accounts
from bank accounts
my my thing was is
have bank accounts the united states
mexico
canada
and then finally bounce over to estonia
was the final destination of all this
stuff and the idea is is to try to move
them
to so many places that by the end of the
day it looks legal and you can't trace
it all
if you're ever caught which you
ultimately are but uh so cash-based
businesses you know when you say sorry
to interrupt the cash-based businesses
so you have
money
that needs to
be moved to other people
uh so how does that work what's the
what's the business
your service and you're giving them
money right so you you do the ozark
thing if you want to do that so you can
gamble cash out something like that
silver trips to whatever casinos you've
got
you've got your production company or
your detail company so how many cars you
cleaning today how many companies have
you got to do that
all right
whatever that company is it's got to be
cash based somebody's paying you in cash
is what you're doing you have to have
enough of those cash-based businesses
where it doesn't look funny
all right because if you're a detail
company making a hundred thousand
dollars a month
that's a problem
yeah okay so then you start depositing
into that well
because of the patriot act as a
suspicious activity report sars
came in at 2 500
instead of the 10k that it used to be so
all of a sudden you've got multiple bank
accounts that you've got to set up all
right
fortunately what you also had is you had
a bunch of prepaid debit cards that were
coming into play at the same time so a
combination of
bank accounts
prepaid debits that had ach abilities
attach those as well and you start
running them all together then once it's
out of the united states you don't have
to worry as much you can start funneling
that into
fewer bank accounts until finally you've
got the one main account that's over at
bank letico and estonia at that point
that's what you've got
so much a bunch of hops that end up in a
place that you can't trace and to give
you an idea i was arrested february 8th
2005.
my last seizure was 2010.
got the last seizure notice so
took them they got it but it took him
that long to get to it
so so
how do stories like with script that
come into play here where
he uh had someone who owed him money
kidnapped and tortured so
when does it turn
darker
it turns darker when the more the the
more money you make script was a kid
that uh
he was stealing enough money that he was
able to buy whatever state he wanted to
and he would brag about touring the
countryside and if he saw a property
that he liked he would buy it and that
was not just a brag he was doing that so
this kid is stealing a lot of money at
the same time he's got connections
politically because of his family he's
got connections and that family's got
connections with the ukrainian mob all
right so he's got these inroads and
people are looking out for him and he's
stealing a lot of money at the same time
somebody doesn't pay him
a decent amount of money somebody
doesn't pay him now we had never
with shadow crew with carter planet with
counterfeit library we were basically
the geeks
all right we were the just the
fraudsters the social engineers
we had never really considered violence
the rules that i had in play were hey
we're not we don't do child pornography
we don't do counterfeit currency we
don't do drugs and the only thing we
ended up really obeying was the child
porn stuff except for max butler who you
mentioned earlier
um
script someone rips the guy off
and
he comes online on shadow crew at that
point
and he posts these pictures one day and
i mean it was a detailed narrative
through the pictures had the guy that
rammed in the van had the door open
round and rammed in the van had the guy
tied up had the guy being tortured and
the response was
this is what happens when you steal from
me
and that's the that's the first time
that violence came into play at that
point that's when things got
you start realizing things are getting a
little serious
how did that make you feel
the first response is
can't be real he's he's just that's
he's just doing that
you know he's wanting to send a message
then you're like
no that's real
that's real and uh
were you afraid in your own heart that
you might uh descend to that too like if
you see that
or was it pretty clear to you that
that's a that's a line that some people
can cross and some can and you're not
one of those that can cross it you know
i got to tell you i joke with my wife
the the joke i get this joke i tell my
wife is you know if i knew some guy that
had 8 000 bitcoins
i might be persuaded to ask him
for access to that and she was like how
and i was like well hammer and toes yeah
and
i say that as a joke
but there's that line
where you're like i remember who i used
to be
and
if you're looking at that kind of money
i might be persuaded to do that back
then
you know that's that's
and i think that's what was scripps
issue
is he it was a lot of money to him this
is the money and then there's
you know violence can also be gradual so
over time you do a little more a little
more a little more a little more
you get used to what's going on and then
like it desensitizes and you figure you
take somebody like uh like ross ulbrick
the the silk road guy all right
ross was not a violent guy
he's he was not but at that point in
time you know he was sitting on 24 24
million in bitcoin he was the only game
in town
and that 24 now is like i don't know 20
to 24 billion some crap like that but uh
he
felt in danger
of
this guy was going to turn him in you
know it was a black mountain and
everything so ross
thinks he hires a couple hit men to kill
the guy so it's it's it becomes that
thing and i saw that over and over again
and i'd like to say i wasn't like that
but
given the same circumstances i would
have probably done the same thing
and also when you're it's not just about
money there's a lot of other forces like
if you're threatened
for your well-being or for your wealth
or for your power all all of us all the
different motivations plus that that
online aspect with those communities
like that if you're the head guy you
really feel like you're the parent of
these guys yeah so somebody's starting
to threaten them it's like all right
what i need to do
you